Archimedes is
draining his bathtub.
Every 2 minutes that pass, 7
gallons of water are drained.
Which of the following functions
can represent the number
of gallons of water
in the tub, W,
as a function of the
minutes that have passed, T?
So let's think
about this visually.
So let's plot the number of
gallons of water we have.
Let's put that in
the vertical axis.
That is a function of time.
As time passes, we will
lose water at a fixed rate.
So this is our time
axis right over here.
So we're going to start with
some initial volume of water
in the tub.
And they actually
don't tell us what
our initial volume of water is.
But let's just call
that capital W sub 0.
So this is just the
initial volume of water.
We're doing
everything in gallons,
so let's say the initial
number of gallons
or the number of gallons
at time equals 0.
This is T equals
zero right over here.
Then they tell us it every 2
minutes that pass-- so time
is going to be given in minutes.
Time is in minutes, and the W is
in gallons-- 7 gallons of water
are drained.
So let's say 2 minutes
pass from time equals 0.
So this is 1 minute, and this
is 2 minutes right over here.
So we have 2 minutes passing.
And how much water is
going to get drained?
Well they tell 7 gallons
of water are drained.
So after 2 minutes, we're
going to get to W0 minus 7.
However much water
we had before,
we're going to have
7 gallons less.
W0 minus 7 is where we go.
And so if we were to plot
the amount of gallons
or the number of gallons we
have as a function of time,
it would look
something like this.
It would look like a line
that goes something like that.
So one thing that we
could ask ourselves
is, what is the rate of
change of W with respect to T?
What is the rate of change of
our vertical axis with respect
to our horizontal axis?
And that's also known as
the slope of our line.
So we could write that
as the rate of change--
this Delta symbol, this
Greek letter, this triangle,
is just shorthand for change
in-- so our change in W
for a given change
in time, well we
know that when time increases
by 2 minutes-- and time
is in minutes-- W
decreases by 7 gallons.
Because it decreases,
it's going down.
And we see that.
This is a downward sloping
line right over here.
And we see it graphically
right over here.
When our change in time
is equal to positive 2,
our change in volume-- so
this is this distance, which
is the same thing as this
distance right over here--
our change in the number of
gallons is equal to negative 7.
So this right over here
is the slope of our line
or the rate of change
of the number of gallons
with respect to time.
Now, we don't know the
exact starting position
or the exact W intercept.
But we just called it W sub 0.
So we could write a
general equation here.
We could say that
the number of gallons
is equal to the
initial gallons that we
have plus negative
7/2 times time.
Or we could just
call this minus 7/2--
that's just the negative 7/2
right over there-- times time.
And this should make
complete sense now.
We have our vertical
axis intercept, often
called the y-intercept.
But this isn't called
the y-axis anymore.
We have our vertical intercept.
And we also have the
slope of our line here.
If you're familiar with
slope-intercept form,
we'd normally write y is
equal to mx plus b, where this
is the slope and this
is the y-intercept.
We've written it
the exact same way.
We've said W is equal to
negative 7/2 T plus W0.
I just swapped these
two things around.
And notice, this is the slope,
and this is the y-intercept.
So which of these
match that pattern?
Well let's see, I should start
with some positive number
of gallons.
And I'm subtracting
7/2 T. So the only one
that matches this is
this one right over here,
is 50 minus 7/2 T. Now even
if you didn't think anything
about slopes and you were just
looking at these choices here,
you would say,
well look, I should
start with a certain
number of gallons of water,
and then it should
only decreases
as the amount of time passes.
This one wouldn't satisfy this.
At time equals 0, I
have no gallons here.
That doesn't meet
the constraints here.
I have a certain
number of gallons
here, so this
doesn't make sense.
Here at time equals
0, I have 100 gallons.
But then as time passes,
that will only increase.
So this is the faucet's on here.
It's not being drained.
So that doesn't work.
Here, once again, I'm
starting with a certain number
of gallons when time equals 0.
And then as time
passes, it's increasing
my number of gallons.
So once again, the faucet
is on right over here.
So once again,
the only one where
I'm starting with a
certain number of gallons
and then as time passes
my number of gallons
are reducing-- because
this is a negative value--
is this choice right over here.